[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday June 12th
or should I say good morning
nerdfighters since Hank is just right
down at the beach and I could go talk to
him if I wanted to so good morning
nerdfighters it's Tuesday June 12th for
today's video I thought I would take the
rare opportunity of actually being in
the same place as Hank to observe what
Hank is like when he's not filming
Brotherhood 2.0 in essence I wanted to
capture for you what Hank green is like
in the wild think of me as your one-man
Hank green paparazzi team it turns out
that Hank is exactly like we'd expect
him to be in a lot of ways he enjoys his
breakfast he likes reading magazines and
he enjoys walking along the beach at
sunset and looking you know wistful but
there is one important way that Hank is
different from what we might expect and
it's this Hank green loves to sleep I
haven't seen someone sleep this much
since the last time I hung out with a
three-day-old so I'll say hey Hank do
you want to go to the beach and he'll
say and then I'll say hey Hank do you
want to go play tennis I heard they have
tennis courts and then he'll say and
then I'll say hey Hank you want to go
fishing in the ocean and he'll say
alright but only if I get to sleep on
the boat I think we have to consider the
possibility that The Weather Channel is
doing sleep deprivation tests on Hank so
anyway nerdfighters I had a great day
surreptitiously filming Hank and then
finally at the end of the day he caught
me well I'm doing an anthropological
study of what Hank green is like when
he's not filming Brotherhood 2.0 videos
yeah
I was gonna go pee I'll go with you
how's it going Hank when Hank green peas
is it like other people peeing Hank how
was it your fans want answers what does
Hank green peeing like apparently a lot
like video John's filming my every move
what's it like when Hank green peas oh
fast hahahaha I'm still on you oh that's
Hank green putting his head in a pillow
okay I'll see you very shortly down at
the beach and you'll see me whenever you
wake up from your nap